finding your purpose guys is not that
difficult it's not that difficult it's
one of the most common questions that I
get here's how you do it I hate spending
money till I'm making money if you do
not have money it's because you are
spending your money on things that are
not making you money the only difference
between you and greatness is the
willingness to grow and improve it's not
Talent it's not smart it's the
willingness to improve yourself need
motivation what's top 10 with belief
nation
I'm Evan Carmichael and here's my take
on my top ten rules of success volume 5
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take ownership of your life if you
woke up and did the thing that made you
feel both and unstoppable and powerful
and confident every single day if you
started your day with that thing your
life would look dramatically different
one year from today compared to where
you currently are right now the problem
is most people wake up like an accident
most people they wake up they check
their phone and they're immediately
responding to other people's emergencies
and demands on your time you're not in
control you haven't decided to take
control of your day that your day is
important that your life is important
and you are going to take ownership of
it and so you need to block off the time
in the morning it may be five minutes
maybe need 15 maybe need an hour and a
half whatever it is the thing that makes
you feel bold unstoppable powerful
confident fill your cup every single day
because other people have demands your
time and they won't fill your cup for
you you have to say this is my ownership
right here nobody's touching it I'm
taking charge now that looks different
for different people how Oprah does it
is different than how I do it is
different than how Dwayne the rock
Johnson does it Dwayne Johnson has to
get his four hours of workout in every
day when he's working on a movie set and
he has to be in by 9:00 he'll wake up at
4:00 in the mornings he can go work out
for four hours and then go back and
shower and get ready for his movie so
he's only sleeping five hours a day when
he's doing movies I think that's crazy
but to him that's balance that's him
filling his cup that's him reminding
himself of what he's doing he loves
working out that's why I don't look like
trying to hog tons and write there's a
difference between us I would rather
sleep I would rather do something else
in the morning and so we tend to look at
what we're doing against somebody else
you tend to look at Oprah and say well
she's doing it this way I need to do
that Dwayne's doing it this way I need
to do that
Evans doing it this way I need to do
that you judge yourself against other
people's routines and methods of filling
their cup and I think that's actually
recipe for failure because you are not
that person because what works for them
is not going to be the exact same thing
that works for you here's the good news
you already know what fills your cup
you already know what makes you feel
bold and alive and full of momentum and
confidence you have had that happen to
you in the past
you're just not living there
consistently you know what has helped
you feel full but you live in their 1%
of the time and 99% of the time you
spend reacting to other people their
domains their emergencies their issues
for your time and so reverse-engineered
for yourself when was the last time you
felt filled up motivated confident bold
excited what happened what were you
doing what led to that thing to happen
were you watching a video will you
listen to a podcast we're reading the
book we're going to an event a seminar
were you outside you know I'm sitting
here on a swing here outside where
you're outside you need to get out of
nature do you need to meditate you need
to have a shower do you need to dance to
music like what's the thing without
judgment without caring if anybody else
has to do that thing maybe you need to
wake up every day and pet your frog and
that's the thing that makes you feel
amazing great do that plan for it every
single morning because I guarantee you
if you did the thing that helped fill
your cup that made you feel bold and
unstoppable and confident and powerful
if all you did was wake up every day and
did that thing your life would be
dramatically different one year from
today compared to where you are right
now you will not recognize your life so
please stop waking up like an accident
and put this into your morning routine
every single day rule number two find
your purpose finding your purpose guys
is not that difficult it's not that
difficult it's one of the most common
questions that I get here's how you do
it you think about the time in your life
where you felt the most worthless think
about the time the lowest low that
you've ever experienced in your life
what was that moment your purpose now
where you will get the most fulfilled of
all time will be helping people who are
currently going through the thing that
you went through
that's it think about the most painful
moments of your life the thing that you
would never want to experience ever
again think about the thing you would
never wish upon your worst enemy
definitely not your friends or family
your kids think about that moment your
greatest purpose your greatest enjoyment
your greatest fulfillment in life will
come from helping people who are
currently facing that thing that you
faced that is your purpose for life it
will never get old helping those people
will never get tiring rule number three
grow and improve self-improvement is the
answer to whatever obstacle is staring
you in the face right now the only
difference between you and greatness is
the willingness to grow and improve it's
not talent it's not smart it's the
willingness to improve yourself the
difference between you and Tony Robbins
is he has spent more time constantly
improving himself than most people on
the planet here's a guy who had multiple
fathers growing up had an abusive mother
who had 17 he had to run away from home
so he could become a janitor and never
go to college he then decided to be a
success he read 700 books in seven years
he studied under mentors like Jim Rohn
and today he's the founder or owner of
companies with over 6 billion dollars in
annual revenue if Tony Robbins can go
from being an abused janitor with no
college education to being one of the
most influential people in the world why
can't you the difference is he made the
investment to constantly improve himself
and you haven't yet at that level so I
look at my channel as an example my
youtube channel and I've learned so much
over the past number of years in
confidence and growth and abilities and
skills by consuming the content because
I love the top 10 series and the men to
me Series in the interests of series I
make them for me and then I share them
with you and thankfully you guys like
them too and I can build a business off
of it and keep pumping out more content
but it helps me I've grown I've learned
and one of the biggest moments that
helped me realize how much I've learned
is when I signed a three-year deal with
sage I was working with Steven Kelly who
was the CEO and every month we'd be on a
call we'd be doing a hangout on my
YouTube channel and
questions from people and I was driving
with my dad and I remember him asking me
how do you get the confidence to be on a
call with Stephen Kelly and be seen as
his equal all the time and he wasn't
asking me to put me down he was asking
me in ingenuine off he was so happy for
me that I was playing a bigger game and
it dawned on me that he was right the
Evan of five years ago wouldn't have
been able to do that the Evan of five
years ago would have felt less than the
Evan of five years ago would have said
there's no way I'm capable of doing that
and then when I'd signed the deal I felt
like it's great I love Stephen he's
amazing but I feel like I'm hanging out
with Oprah and Kanye and Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates and these super successful
people and they're infiltrating my brain
on a daily basis right a daily basis
three videos every single day on this
channel and so bit by bit it pulls me up
now I've recognized I still have a long
way to go I still have so much more to
learn I still need to believe in myself
even more and every time I consume more
content it allows me to grow my comfort
zone a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit more and the funny
thing is all of these moments are little
tiny incremental parts of your growth I
couldn't point you to one point in my
past where I said that was the moment
that I changed that was the moment that
I had more confidence but as I studied
every day every day every day I could
look back three months six months a year
and say wow I've really changed I've
really grown I've really learned a lot
but in the daily from today the
yesterday I'd say I didn't grow at all
and so sometimes on your journeys are
trying to learn and get better you may
feel like the growth is really slow on a
daily basis but if you keep going you
keep investing you keep learning you
keep seeking out mentors you keep trying
to get better and improve not every day
will be amazing but if you try every day
to get better and learn I can guarantee
you that in three months six months one
year when you look back of the person
you've become compared to what you are
right now there'll be a big change and
that's because you continue to invest in
yourself rule number four start small I
hate spending money till and making
money if you do not have money it's
because you are spending your
money on things that are not making new
money this is what happens in so many
entrepreneurs businesses when you're
starting you go and you spend a whole
bunch of money on different gear
equipment samples products and then it
doesn't work out instead of going out
and spending money at the start find a
way to get started on the cheap
investing your energy your hustle your
drive your initiative but not your money
here's what happens someone wants to
start a t-shirt business okay great
to get the price discounts that you want
to that on a per teacher basis it's
cheaper you have to order 5,000 t-shirts
so you go out and you spend all your
money ordering 5,000 t-shirts or worse
you go take a loan so you can get your
5,000 t-shirts the t-shirts come in
yourself three of them and then you have
four thousand nine hundred and ninety
seven t-shirts sitting in your mom's
basement
that's most people you'll spend money
because you've got this ambitious dream
envisioning it see in your head how it's
all gonna work out but then when you get
started it never works out if you think
it's gonna work out when I first started
on YouTube I had a team of eight or so
people are ready in my other business in
my main business and so I'm gonna try
this thing on the side just as a fun
thing and see how it goes I did
everything myself myself I did
everything myself invest my energy my
heart my hustle my drive my intuition
into making something happen and once I
started making some money then I could
invest into building a team into getting
gear into building this business up so
now we've got 24 people on the team when
I first started doing my Instagram live
morning shows it was me and my tripod
and a cell phone and a guest and we went
live on Instagram every day and then
people said hey you should get a
microphone okay great I got a quick
little microphone that connected and we
went now this thing might be the future
that maybe all I do I might even close
down YouTube and just do Instagram lives
and if that happens and I'll invest in
the team and making that happen maybe in
three years if I'm still doing it
there'll be 20 people in the room from a
producer and camera people and editors
and everybody's in the room guiding the
show right that might be the future but
I don't know I got to start by just
doing one show you do not have money
because you're spending your money
the things that are not working and
generating money back for you
so stop spending money stop stop it
right now stop spending money on things
that don't make you money instead invest
your energy your hustle your time your
drive as a default until you're making a
little bit of money from that thing a
little bit of money from that thing and
then you can invest that money to make
more money if you want to learn how to
build confidence like myself and other
entrepreneurs check out my to 54 series
it's in the description below and it is
free if you're doing work that you love
you're more likely to follow through
you're more likely to do it because it
doesn't feel like work because you love
doing it surround yourself with
greatness if you want to be more
confident you need to surround yourself
with things that make you feel confident
rule number five love the process if you
are thinking about how many hours you're
working and you're frustrated and you're
complaining I think you've lost I can
think if you are counting down as an
entrepreneur how many more hours to go
until the day is over until you get to
go on your vacation until the weekend is
here I think you've lost like I
genuinely think you've lost you have to
love the work if you look at look at all
of the people that have done profiles on
across entrepreneurship athletics
singing everybody they love the work you
have to love the process not just the
results it's why you have to love it so
much to put through all the crap all the
negativity all the burnout all of the
stuff that happens to you as an
entrepreneur you have to deal with it
and the only thing that gets you through
is you love it I love making videos I'm
here in Albuquerque Nina's getting her
nails done Danny's getting his shirt as
phone charged in the car and I'm making
videos cuz I love making videos because
I can't wait to make videos I've done
6000 plus videos on my channel and I
can't wait to make more I love it I love
the process I love helping entrepreneurs
I love the result and a little process
and yes that can cause personal issues
that can cause health breakdowns that
can cause you to get stressed out that
can cause you to push beyond your limits
that can cause you how issues again
relationship issue is a can and the does
for so many entrepreneurs and yes you
need to guard for that you need to watch
for that you need to be able to create
an intentional life not just
can working working working working
working all the time and then you die
but you need to love the work you need
to love the process it's not painful to
do it same pay the price it's not
painful to pay the price for you
separate into my schedule making six
thousand videos you might think is
really painful for me it's not like I
love it it's great it's amazing and that
should be the same thing in your
business people who say it's a will do
whatever it takes going wrong you won't
do whatever it takes because as soon as
it starts getting really hard you're
gonna quit where somebody who actually
loves that thing will keep going because
they love it and you don't and whenever
you're up against somebody who loves to
work and you don't they will destroy you
even if you have more natural talent
they will destroy you because they love
the work and you don't it makes all the
difference in the world rule number six
stop complaining your entire life
changes when you decide to take
responsibility to where you're at for it
for your happiness for your success for
you where you're at in life when you
decide that I am responsible everything
changes we don't want to because it's
easier to blame somebody else it's
easier to blame somebody else we don't
blame the person in the mirror and we
don't blame ourselves somebody else's
fault right it's Nina's fault that I'm
not happy where are you Nina it's so
good to put the blame on somebody else
because that means I don't have to do
anything but when you take the personal
responsibility when I say it's my fault
that I'm not happy it's my fault that
I'm not more successful it's not my
team's fault that my company's done
blowing up as big as I wanted to it's my
fault I need to get better it's not my
trainers fault that I'm not getting
results in the gym it's my fault right I
gotta eat better I gotta work out more
it's my fault it's your fault you are
where you are because of you and when
you accept that then you choose to now
live a life I'll be able to make
progress most people don't want to do
that most people would rather consume
entertainment instead of education most
people would rather consume
entertainment and sit down and watch
Netflix and forget about their crappy
life and try to fix it most channels on
YouTube that blow up are not
occasion related their entertainment
because people want to shut up their
lives
shut up their brain and just be
entertained instead of trying to
actually fix the problem if you're a
subscriber here you're probably under
the kitchen side but a unit had a person
who's gonna take responsibility and fix
your life or just shut up the world
blame complain which you can't have that
next vacation you can't wait till that
next weekend do the evenings are coming
up because your life sucks your life
sucks is it your fault or somebody
else's when you think ownership that's
when life starts to change rule number
seven surround yourself with success the
fastest way to grow is to be around
people who are doing what you want to do
period when you are around people who
are building and growing and taking on
the world and trying to accomplish their
dreams and you're in that environment
and you're learning even just being
around them it's gonna seep into you and
get you motivated and pumped up and
fired up to go off and chase your dreams
most people will have a pretty crappy
environment most people if you got an
entrepreneur most people they don't have
a bunch of entrepreneurs in their family
most people when they tell their family
and friends what they're doing they
think they're crazy they think that you
shouldn't go off and do that thing you
should go and get a safe normal typical
job a lot of people have a lot of
negativity around them if you are
constantly surrounded by negative people
people bringing you down it's really
hard to be the one person trying to go
off and make a huge difference and so
that's you if that's your situation then
you need to change your environment you
need to be surrounded by people who are
like-minded who are off chasing their
goals and you need to find some mentors
let me give some quick tips on how to do
it because if you don't you're never
gonna get to where you want to go you
won't stain right now where you are
needs to be unacceptable needs to be
unacceptable because you will never get
to the spot that you want to be at if
you stay exactly where you are with the
people in the environment that you have
around you step number one is limit the
exposure to negativity that may mean you
cut off some friends just because your
friends in elementary school doesn't
mean you should still be friends now it
doesn't doesn't mean have to be rude to
them you've just grown apart it's okay
it's okay it's great you go get new
friends we need to limit exposure to
negative toxic people if those are your
parents you may not want to completely
eliminate them from your life although
for some people that's a important
step it may just mean cutting off
exposure to some topics if you know that
your friends or your parents talk to
them about your business ideas is always
going to lead to a fight and negativity
just don't talk about it say I don't
want to talk about that and find
something positive that you can relate
to and talk about step one you have to
eliminate the negativity or limit
exposure to it in your life you will not
do great things if you are constantly
bombarded by negativity step number two
now you have to fill the void you gotta
fill the void with positivity and so
that's reaching out that's joining
communities that's going to events
that's going to groups I'm on like tour
right now I'm in Albuquerque New Mexico
I'm doing an event tonight here in
Albuquerque and when people come
together who are like-minded all the
people who come to my events they're all
entrepreneurs and they all want to go
out and do something amazing and for a
lot of the people coming out they're the
only ones that they know who are off
trying to do something and now they meet
local people who are also similarly
minded you need to be around similarly
minded people and so check your local
city check your local groups see what's
happening see what's coming up and get
involved get out of the house stop being
in your regular routine your your
current environment is not helping you
you need to get out and meet new people
and you may go to an event and meet only
one person that is potentially
like-minded amazing collect people I
like collecting good people collect them
I'll even be super awkward about it
almost intentionally where if I really
like somebody and we have a great
conversation I'll say you know what I
really like you that sounds weird I'd
like to find a way to spend more time
together and maybe we meet up once a
month for a coffee and just talk about
business that's how you do it you just
ask and if you had that with four or
five different people then every week
you're meeting somebody on a regular
basis who fills you with positivity and
energy and so you have to go out and
find those people you have to say yes to
go to those events to meet to be around
the positive energy because it'll make
such a big difference you accomplishing
your big goals and then step number
three is get more Mentors you need to
get Mentors and one our aspirational
Mentors and that's what I see through
what I do right through my content I
learned through the aspirational Mentors
I learned
Kanye I learned from Dutton upon me I
learned from Oprah Winfrey I learned
from Mel Robbins I learned from these
people they make me better even though I
haven't met most of the people that I've
profiled on my channel I learned from
them they make me better being around
them and their energy and their wisdom
gets me fired up seeing people going off
doing amazing things and I get that
three times a day on my channel right
like it will shift you it will if you
are watching content you may never meet
on the Ponte but if you're watching his
content if he inspires you and you watch
his content on a daily it will shift you
because now he's a voice of positivity
in your life and then you can get real
mentors as well for those of you who are
following my path to 10 million
subscribers series I'm having people who
I respect to look up to coach me on
different things and I need to get
better at who they'll watch my stuff and
say hey here this is where you're great
but here you suck you got to get better
at this thing you need to make the
decision to change your environment you
need to make the decision that your life
is important that your mission is
important that being where you are right
now is not acceptable that you don't
want to be here again in a year like one
year from today you can't be in the same
environment you can't be around
negativity and toxicity every single day
you need to follow those steps you need
to remove the negativity from your life
you need to seek out positive energy and
be around people who build and lift you
up and you need to start seeking out
mentors whether they are face-to-face
mentors or aspirational mentors to help
you get to where you go your life is
important your mission is important you
need to start treating it as so rule
number eight change your mindset you're
never gonna accomplish anything great if
you're coming from a place as negativity
if you were just complaining and
negative and blaming other people you're
never gonna accomplish anything it's
just not gonna happen you can't create
amazing things from a negative spot it
means that you have zero resourceful
Ness because there's no hope and so you
need to flip it now I'm gonna give you a
wild mind trick that I use that maybe is
a little too weird duck for you but I
want to test it on you because if one of
you picks it up it'll dramatically
change your life it's my philosophy of
changing negative situations and doing a
quick mind trick in my head to say is
the best so whenever I'm hit with a
negative situation something that is
beyond my control
something that
do anything about it I will complain I
will be unhappy I'll be negative for 8
to 24 seconds and then I'll tell myself
it's the best then this is the best
thing that happened to me and they'll
figure out why it's the best so as an
example I want an airplane I'm coming
from Vancouver to LA I'm speaking at an
event in LA I want to fly it it's a
five-hour flight I get on and this is
really smelly dude next to me really
smelly guy he probably hadn't been on
you know in a shower in a couple days
probably had multiple transfers and
stopovers and I have empathy I'm not I'm
not pissed at him I'm Kris it's a
situation right I'm sure he's normally a
nice smelling guy and takes care of
himself but in this situation he was
super smelly and I had to deal with it
so what am I gonna do I've got a five
hour flight what are my options I can
not go you know I could miss my flight
and then not do my presentation I could
sit on the airplane and be upset for the
next five hours and then be upset for
the rest of the day and allow this minor
situation to own mean to be better than
me and ruin my entire date or I could
say this is the best and that's what I
did for around 8 to 24 seconds I'm
sitting there trying to figure out my
options what options do I have
how can I do how can I fix this there's
no option so I'm screwed
and then I'm upset you know upset this
sucks come on really
this is what I have to deal with her the
next five hours and then this is the
best and what do I do
yeah breathe it in breathe it give it to
me because this is making me stronger
this is the best this is actually the
best why because it's my chance to show
myself what I made of that this smelly
dude is not gonna own me that I am
stronger than a little bit of smell on
an airplane and then the next time I get
faced with a similar situation I'm able
to handle it it's easy it rubs off me I
think that's how you actually build
self-confidence that's how you actually
build self-esteem because when it's easy
it's easy when in a race against
three-year-olds is easy doesn't mean
anything you're not gonna clap that up
yeah I beat a bunch of three-year-olds
but when it's hard and you try that's
when you actually build self-esteem and
so flip it flip it in your mind flip it
this is the fast whatever a negative
situation is running right now tell
yourself it's the best rule number nine
get attention
people often ask me what is your
business but 11 how do you make money
this is it this is my business model I
kick up as much noise in my industry I
get as much attention as possible in my
industry and then I find ways to
monetize it that's it when you have a
lot of attention in your industry people
will find you and throw opportunities at
you
my biggest challenge is trying to figure
out now which opportunity to go after I
get speaking gigs because of the
attention I built my youtube channel I
get opportunities to connect with people
like Tony Robbins and have them be
interviewed on my channel I get brand
deals that people wanted to partner with
me I get book deals everything has come
because of my youtube channel because I
built up a quarter of a billion views
because I have one point whatever
million subscribers I just pick up a lot
of attention in my industry and then
deals come to me and that works really
well for someone like me because I'm
introverted because I'm much better at
marketing than I am at sales and so
instead of me spending time which would
be more wasted time going out trying to
connect with people trying to reach
people because I'm introverted I just
get to work on creating amazing content
and I have people then find me and find
me out the places and pay me to do
things because I built up the marketing
attention machine and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is have
mission when you have a mission you're
not for sale when you know what you're
doing when you have a deep purpose and
you are off chasing it you are not for
sale money is really important but if
you look at the success of people look
at anybody who look up to who you
respect who's your hero who's your hero
who's your greatest most famous
entrepreneur of all time that you love
and you would love to emulate money was
not the most important thing to them
there was something above money now
money is important money is important
for every business money is important
for every organization if you're a
charity money's still important but it's
not number one and you gotta figure out
what you would put ahead of your money
so many people are just chasing money
money money money and I get it it's
important I had I had a woman who was at
my seminar last night here in
Indianapolis who she has eight different
side hustles and now she's trying to get
into real estate to try to make money
and the problem is none of its purpose
driven another hood is actually making
her enough money she's making just
enough just little tiny bits from these
side hustles that she can barely survive
it's the wrong path the people who only
prioritize money never make money they
never make the real money you make just
enough to survive because your will to
win is for sale you've got to figure out
what your purpose is you got to figure
out who you are you got to figure out
what the mission is that you're on when
you do that then no matter how much
money is being thrown at you you're not
gonna accept it because you're on a deep
purpose for life now I've got to stretch
the bone and skip on how to think long
term that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that time for the three-point
landing questions let's move from just
watching a video to taking action in
your life or business here we go
question number one what's your mission
number two what's the biggest change in
your mindset that you need to shift and
number three how can you just start
small on one of your ideas right now
people lack perspective and so they make
stupid short-term decisions you see it
in health we'd rather eat the Doritos or
those Junior Mints because it gives us
that short-term burst meanwhile it's
sacrificing our long-term health you see
it in entrepreneurship all the time
where people are constantly jumping from
one opportunity to the next just trying
to make money just trying to pay off
some bills and having 18 different side
hustles meanwhile never actually
anything of substance we make stupid
short-term decisions and we don't have
perspective to think about the long term
I had a woman come out on my tour who
she's trying to build this charity and
she's trying to build this amazing
business for herself but meanwhile she's
got eight different side hustles from
ice cream trucks to a whole bunch of
different side and none of them are
working like they're working just enough
to pay a little bit of money and so you
stick with it cuz it gives you that
little tiny taste meanwhile you're not
building anything towards the long term
it's why people can't get out of their
cell phones and can't get off of their
emails I used to pride myself as being
the guy who would answer an email within
a minute and a half right like quick
boom you send me an email you get a
response ASAP right away that's good
customer service right and then people
would respond back and say wow you're so
fast on Iman that fed the dopamine right
like I'm getting these little quick hits
but what happened nothing got done on my
big projects nothing got done on my big
projects because I constantly was being
distracted and handling these little
tiny balls instead of working towards
the big ones you can't be a master of
both at the same time you have to decide
I'm either gonna go for the big things
in life my big goals my big mission my
big vision or I'm gonna go for the
little small ones constantly and if you
go for the big ones it means you're
gonna have to give up some of the small
ones some small things are gonna get
through the cracks that's okay but if
you're only focused on the small things
you will never hit your big goals theory
so I think it's an issue of perspective
we forget about the long-term we forget
about the long-run because it's so far
away because you don't want to think
about the rest of your life you think
about what's happening right now you're
tired now you're hungry now you need
money right now you think about the now
and you lose perspective over where
you're going and so you make stupid
short-term decisions
if you want more Evan Chicka the other
top ten rules really we made the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there people who win work the
hardest because they love what they do
if you just focus on the money you're
never gonna get it this is what so many
entrepreneurs do and why so many
entrepreneurs fail